Welcome, everybody.
It's been a very long night.
It is the first day after the 20 20 presidential
Senate and House election and unfortunately,
we really don't have that many results yet,
at least not enough to say who will be the
president of the United States for the next
four years.
And it's really difficult to do these shows
because things move so quickly and then nothing
happens for hours and things move quickly.
And because it takes us about 90 minutes to
produce the show, I try in the interests of
getting you all the most updated and accurate
information on which we can then go to the
next day.
It becomes tough to know exactly when to do
the show, but at a certain point we have to
do it and we're doing it right now.
So I will give you the information that is
accurate as of this moment, some of this may
have changed.
And if so, at our next opportunity to be together,
we will discuss it.
There is not yet a winner in the 2020 presidential
election.
I will look at specific numbers with you in
a little bit.
But as of this morning, the Associated Press
had it.
Two hundred and thirty eight electoral votes
for Joseph R. Biden Jr., the Democratic candidate,
and 213 electoral votes for Donald Trump.
And yet Donald Trump declared victory late
last night, early this morning.
I will have clips of that for you.
That is exactly as I predicted.
But the most important reminder I have, and
this was starting to become an issue on last
night's dream.
We anticipated this scenario.
We had over one and a half million different
people, including nearly 100000 at a time,
watched the live stream of the results last
night and panic was rapidly rising.
I had people in Europe calling.
It was 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning there.
They were up all night watching the numbers.
We have to remember the Red Mirage scenario
now.
Trump may win.
Biden may win.
This was an election because we knew that
there were going to be postal delays partially
caused by the president's postmaster general.
There are now 300000 potentially missing ballots,
which I will tell you about.
I will tell you all of what is going on.
Some states which count in person and report
in-person ballots first and then start counting
the mail in ballots.
We knew of a potential red meraj scenario
where states would look like they were going
Trump.
And as the ballots are counted, they start
looking towards Biden.
We already have two examples of this.
Wisconsin and Michigan.
They are not final numbers yet, but Wisconsin
and Michigan all night yesterday, even until
midnight.
And later, we're looking like, wow, Trump's
crushing Michigan.
And slowly but surely, the numbers have shifted
and are now leaning in favor of Joseph R.
Biden Jr..
So panic does not serve us well in these situations.
We don't think clearly when we're panicking.
And importantly, we're panicking over things
we can't control.
If we learn about ballots being thrown out,
then, yes, we activate and we start calling
the people who need to be called and complaining
and making a lot of noise, but merely waiting
for ballots to be counted when we anticipated
a Red Mirage scenario doesn't serve us well.
And in fact, as I tweeted last night around
twelve thirty in the morning, remember how
we were warned about a red meraj and not to
panic at midnight on Tuesday?
I'm going to bed.
Many vote counts don't even resume until the
morning.
And indeed, that's what I did.
And indeed, as the vote counts have resumed,
the numbers have started to shift in Joe Biden's
favor in a number of states.
I'm speaking generally now.
I will get to specifics in the next segment.
Now, as a quick reminder, in the midst of
all of this, remember, we still have a pandemic.
We had another nearly 100000 cases yesterday.
And on top of all of the normal delays that
can sometimes happen on top of the delays
that we're aware of in the mail, on top of
all of these other things, most states are
also being relatively safe when it comes to
the pandemic in terms of elections staff and
counting and all of these things.
So let's not forget about that reality as
we discussed the election results.
So momentarily we're going to do a deep dove
into the presidential map.
In terms of the Senate, we still don't know
who will control the Senate right now.
Democrats have flipped two seats, John Hickenlooper,
one in Colorado, and Mark Kelly defeating
the incumbent Republican vile Republican Martha
McSally in Arizona.
Republicans have also flipped one seat.
We expected that Democratic Senator Doug Jones
would lose in Alabama and he did.
So that's Democrats plus two Republicans plus
one.
That is one seat in the direction of Democrats
so far.
Otherwise, counting continues in the House
of Representatives, votes still being counted
as of one.
A moment earlier today, Democrats securing
one hundred and ninety seats, flipping to
firm Republicans, Republicans securing one
hundred and eighty one, flipping six, meaning
a net gain of four for Republicans with 64
seats remaining to count.
I'm going to take some time to go through
the presidential numbers in a moment.
This is going to take some time.
As long as we're confident in the votes being
counted, it doesn't bother me, although I
understand it is stressful and anxiety producing.
The problem we're up against is Donald Trump
is trying to end the election.
Now, Donald Trump has declared victory.
Donald Trump declared that he won states,
which it's not actually clear that he won.
And we know of hundreds of thousands of votes
that are potentially missing.
And we're going to cover
all of
it
for you today.